let's move on Sri Lanka's newly elected
president got to bio Rajapaksa has sworn
in his own brother as Prime Minister
Mahinda Rajapaksa served as president
for 10 years got a pile Rajapaksa has
vowed to be tough on security issues in
light of the Easter bombings that
happened earlier this year let's go live
now to Colombo Al Jazeera's minal
Fernandes can tell us more about the
swearing-in ceremony and whether the
Rajapaksa spinel have got down to work
yet
absolutely Adrian it started earlier
today when Mahinda Rajapaksa the former
president took his oath of office before
his younger brother the new president
gotta be Rajapaksa now obviously this
marks a sort of a return and a reversal
of the Rajapaksa fortunes bear in mind
that elder brother minder was voted out
of office in 2015 as he attempted to win
a third term however this entire result
and the last couple of days has marked
essentially a public sort of a reversal
in terms of Hocking back to the
Rajapakse is very much an acknowledgment
that their priorities have shifted since
those April East bombings where the
concerns that national securities needs
some one sort of capable and their
income the Rajapaksa as they've proved
as the majority has voted that they
managed to bring to an end the 26-year
civil war get a handle on nationally and
they're promising to do once again go to
a barrage apart so the president has
replaced all the governors in the
provinces of Sri Lanka we had all the
new appointments coming through we've
also had my in the Rajapaksa the new
prime minister actually starting work
today this is actually the official
prime minister's office he was here for
about three hours today not just to
symbolically and ceremonially sort of
sign his first documents but also to
have a series of meetings he was holed
up with basically his supporters his
loyalists his party obviously mapping
out the next couple of days we did see
behind the Raja Parks's
newly appointed secretary the secretary
the president walking in there was a lot
of activity because the first thing that
Mahinda Rajapaksa has to do after his
appointment as prime minister obviously
is to name his cabinet we're hearing
that that cabinet will be named on
friday and one sort of key thing that
has been talked about is that this
cabinet which will be very much a sort
of an interim government until elections
take place for the new parliament that
that cabin
is going to be limited to sort of around
15 ministers now that itself is a
mammoth trust I mean particularly in
terms of the bartering going on in terms
of all the support that the Rajapaksa
has got everybody will want a piece of
the action but that's going to be one of
their first challenges limited limiting
that cabinet and basically mapping out
the next couple of days Adrienne but how
many thanks indeed men often and is
there live in Colombo